Let's go to I believe this is Kendall from
is at San Mateo.
It's sort of too long for me to see.
I know it's Kendall, though.
Can you hear me, David?
Yes, I can.
It's San Marcos, Texas.
Oh, San Marcos.
OK, very good.
Yeah, sorry I'm super white so I always pronounce
it San Marcos.
No.
So my question was, is.
With had pulled up here with the GSA, the
GSA announcing that they'd be letting the
transition go through.
Have you noticed?
I just wanted to get your take on the notable
further break down what seems of Trump's psyche
as he's been tweeting, because after the GSA
tweet sent out the letter and Trump said he
would be allowing the GSA, he's been retweeting
just some really strange things from like
actors, especially.
He's been he looks like you retweeted Randy
Quaid like four times.
Listen, what's going on with Trump is he is
furious that the attention is shifting to
Joe Biden, as it should, because Trump has
given up on the virus and Biden is now running
a coronavirus task force.
Joe Biden is building a cabinet.
Joe Biden will soon be president.
And what you are seeing are the last gasps
of Trump's narcissistic ego.
And so he just can't stop.
And the my guess is that Trump tweeting that
he's allowing the transition to go forward,
even though he still thinks he won.
I think that that is likely to be as close
as we get to a concession from Donald Trump.
But I would expect him to continue tweeting
for a while.
When the election is certified on December
14th, he may start doing less of it.
And we may even see Trump just kind of go
off tomorrow, logo around Christmastime and
never come back to D.C.
But this is all ego driven, what you are seeing
right now.
Right.
I was just when I woke up this morning, I
always, you know, I check I have Google read
me the news and then I go through Twitter
and I always check and see if if Trump has
done something incredibly stupid.
And all I see is Randy Quaid.
Yeah, it's there's I don't know that there's
really any rhyme or reason.
Sometimes Trump will do 80 tweets in the middle
of the night.
Sometimes he'll be very quiet.
Trump hasn't taken questions from the press
for for nearly a month.
And I would be I would expect that to continue
for a while, quite frankly.
But we're just going to have to deal with
and deal with it until he finally goes.
OK, well, thank you, David.
And if you ever end up in San Marcus, I know
you're a big foodie, so if you ever end up
in San Marcos, please try a cafe on the square.
It's a restaurant downtown.
It's real good.
All right.
Very good.
I appreciate the recommendation.
It's a good one.
All right, you two, take care.
There we go, checking in there from from Texas.
A lot of viewers, a
lot of viewers in Texas.